SPEAKER: The Associate
Cloud Engineer track
enables you to become proficient
with Google Cloud Platform
through hands-on
practice with Qwiklabs.
The track provides
Qwiklabs credits
that you can use to complete
the labs free of charge.
Here are the steps to
redeem Qwiklabs credits.
At the beginning of the
program, an invitation email
was sent to you from Google
Cloud EDU and Coursera,
and the subject line--
You are invited to
learn on Coursera.
The email provides the link
to redeem Qwiklabs credits
and the access code.
The link in the invitation
email will directly
open Qwiklabs, the Google
Cloud training platform,
and prompt you for
the access code.
Here are the steps
using an example.
Click the invitation link,
copy and paste the access code
as prompted, and click Submit.
Sign into your Qwiklabs account.
Click on Join with Email to
set up your Qwiklabs account.
Set up your Qwiklabs account.
Enter your first name, last
name, and your email address.
Specify the same
email address that you
use for your Coursera account.
For Company Name, specify your
institution's name or none.
Enter password.
Enable the opt-in box
to receive information
about new content
and special discounts
after you complete the
Cloud Architecture quest.
Enable CAPTCHA, and click
Create a New Account.
Once you have created
your Qwiklabs account,
you may verify that
credits have been
added to your Qwiklabs account.
Click on the User Profile to
review your Qwiklabs credit
status.
Click on the User Profile.
Within your User Profile,
click My Account,
and click on Credits
& Subscriptions
for additional Qwiklabs
account information.
Redeeming Qwiklabs credits for
the Associate Cloud Engineer
track is a one-time process.
If you already have
a Qwiklabs account
and enrolled in the Cloud
Architecture quest before,
please un-enroll in the
quest and then click
the Enroll button again.
Only when you click
the Enroll button
will the credits be
applied to your account.
If there are any other problems,
email support@qwiklabs.com.
The team will respond quickly.
We have now reviewed the steps
to redeem Qwiklabs credits,
create your account, verify
that Qwiklabs credits have been
added to your account, and
that support@qwiklabs.com
is your resource for
troubleshooting assistance.